if we could tell ourselves you know if
we could think our way out of anxiety
i would happily find another job it's
just not how our brains work right so
there's this idea of just telling
ourselves to stop being anxious
at best willpower can be delete
depleted throughout the day at worst
and i think the science is leaning in
this direction
we may not really have a whole lot of
willpower maybe more a
you know myth and muscle what we do know
in modern day
is a little bit of neuroscience you know
that that wasn't known back in ancient
greece
and one of the pieces that we do know is
that reward based learning is the
strongest
mechanism in our brain so why not start
there rather than the prefrontal cortex
which ironically goes offline when we're
stressed or we're
tired or you know that's where the halt
acronym comes from you know hungry angry
lonely tired that's when our prefrontal
cortex goes offline
so if that's not accessible or
useful or strong enough why not tap into
the reward-based learning part of the
brain
and it too is relatively simple and has
been the research
has been known for decades about how
this works and it's pretty
so basically there are these two
researchers in the 70s roscorla and
wagner
they developed this model called the
ruskolo wagner model where
we developed this uh basically a
prediction value or a reward value of
different behaviors and the way this is
set up is to help us not have to relearn
everything every day
you know so if given a choice between
two behaviors we don't have to try
the a and then try b and then compare
the two
you know we've tried to know them enough
before that we say oh yeah i'm going to
do b
because i know it's more rewarding than
a so our brains are going to pick what's
more rewarding
so for example i don't know tying your
shoes let's say a is not tying your
shoes b is tying your shoes you realize
if you tie your shoes you don't trip
it's more rewarding we just do it as a
habit okay
so the only way to change a behavior
is by updating that reward value and
that reward value can get laid down
for a long time i don't know we could
use eating or smoking as an example
right so think of all the times we've
eaten cake
you know birthday parties celebrations
all these things that gets laid down as
this
rewarding behavior and then we see okay
can we eat cake because our brain says
that's rewarding
the only way to change that is to bring
awareness to it and the roskorloagner
model talks about
these terms that are sound fancy but
they're pretty straightforward
positive prediction error or a negative
prediction error
so using cake as an example if we
see a piece of chocolate cake and we
haven't had it from a certain bakery
before we
you know we expect it to have you know
oh i like chocolate cake we expect it to
have a certain reward value
then we eat it and we go oh my goodness
this is the best chocolate cake i've
ever had you know in my life and
suddenly
there's this positive prediction error
because we predicted it to be
of x reward and it was actually x plus a
thousand you know it was much
more rewarding so we were like oh i
gotta remember that bakery and we we
learned to go back there for a good
chocolate cake
well let's say we go to the same bakery
and they put a bunch of salt
in the recipe instead of sugar you know
oops and we eat it
and we go ugh what what you know
boy this is not very rewarding we get
this negative prediction error that says
man don't go back to that bakery again
okay
so that's how reward value is updated
all based on one thing
which is awareness we have to pay
attention to the behavior or we're just
going to keep doing it
right and you can see how this applies
to addictions so for example in our
smoking program we have people pay
attention when they smoke and they
realize that cigarettes taste like [ __ ]
and they stop you know
that reward value goes down we've even
we did a study
recently with our eat right now app
where we actually found that within 10
to 12 times of people
paying attention we give them this
craving tool in the app to really pay
attention as they eat
that reward value drops below zero so it
doesn't actually take
that long to update a reward value
whether it's a
addiction like cigarette smoking or even
a habit like overeating cake
right that's super fascinating i i'm
just thinking about
you know i can only uh couch this in my
own
experience and i'm thinking about my
alcoholism
and the self-awareness that i would have
before picking up a drink knowing if i
pick up one
that ain't gonna be the only drink and
god knows what's gonna happen but a
hundred percent
i'm gonna at a minimum i'm gonna wake up
feeling terrible and
there's the possibility that i'm
creating that all kinds of havoc
is going to ensue that's going to have a
very negative impact on my life and yet
i make the choice anyway there's a
powerlessness
over it so um maybe that's a little bit
of a distinction between
somebody who's fully addicted to
something versus an anxiety response
because the counter to that you have an
example in the book of the woman who
does the very thing you just mentioned
which is goes to the bakery
is used to getting you know some kind of
sweet and savory food
she opts for the blackberries instead
and she feels better
afterwards and so she's creating a new
reward mechanism i think piggybacking on
top of that and this is what i
want would like you to get into a little
bit is
she's opting out of that kind of vicious
cycle that takes place
after you've made the choice you know
you're not supposed to make that makes
you feel bad and then you beat yourself
up
and you just continue to dig that hole
deeper so she
arrests that cycle she doesn't have the
shame reaction
she actually feels better physically
hence
she's more likely to make the correct
choice the next time she's carving that
new
neural pathway yes yeah and that's
really the secret sauce
in terms of learning anything whether
it's letting go of an unhealthy habit or
even fostering
a healthy habit is to reflect back
on what it was like last time so as you
described you know that playing the tape
forward
what am i going to get from this well
the only way we can project into the
future
is based on past experience and if
anybody has
enough experience let's say drinking to
excess
that they can clearly see you know 99
out of 100 times i'm going to wake up
with a hangover and
you know with a worse relationship with
my partner or whatever
then that starts to take hold as a
reduced reward value
and if they can recall that then their
brain
says do i really want to have a drink
and the same thing is true
for the eating example it's like if i
overeat again
what am i going to get from this so i
actually like the very simple
i have uh folks in this step two of the
book just ask the simple question
what do i get from this right and again
it's not intellectual it's experiential
like yeah
yeah yeah yeah like try to really
connect with the emotional experience
of of following through on that
unhealthy behavior
and one of the things that i've learned
in recovery is called playing it through
and it's not it's about having a longer
view on
like okay if i'm gonna drink like i'm
gonna i'm gonna
ameliorate this emotional you know
feeling of of dis-ease that i'm
experiencing right now
that's what's triggering me to do it but
play it through like okay then tomorrow
i'm gonna wake up and feel like [ __ ]
i'm not gonna be able to do my job or
study or whatever it is that i have
in store my partner is going to give me
a little bit of side eye you know like
just like play it all the way to its
conclusion not just the reward but
what's on the other side of that reward
[Music]
you